[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro live
vous êtes dans les studios du figaro
vous êtes en direct et on attend vos
points de vue notamment encore
aujourd'hui sur donald trump est il
audacieux et ils décidément
irresponsable on va en débattre
on attend vos points de vue on en débat
avec béatrice giblin bonsoir rédactrice
en chef entre autres de la revue
hérodote
et comme chaque matin mardi avec alexis
brézet bonsoir d'exosun vincent
directeur des rédactions du groupe
figaro l'autre débat qu'on aura ce soir
c'est faut-il s'inquiéter de la
disparition possible du mot séparatisme
du prochain de projet de loi sur la
question au profit du mot laïcité on
attend vos points de vue on en débat
mais d'abord donald trump at il a raison
de dire qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur du
coc vide dix neuf c'est la question
qu'on vous pose sur le site du figaro
depuis la mi-journée question que vous
pose après avoir vu cette séquence que
l'on va on va retrouver revoir les
images de donald trump sur le balcon de
la maison blanche ans devance son masque
après être descendu de l'hélicoptère qui
va leur amener de l'hôpital et après
l'avoir entendu déclarer ceci est donc
la tête d'amnéville alors dans le camp
d'en face on ne partage pas cet
optimisme
on dénonce l'attitude du président
américain du président candidat et je
vous propose d'écouter son challenger
joe biden ce président c'est qui
alors à défaut d'écouter les
scientifiques on va écouter d'abord les
médecins les médecins de donald trump et
voici leur avis alors donald trump
at il raison de dire qu'il ne faut pas
avoir peur du vide 19 c'est la question
qu'on pose sur le site du figaro est
pour l'instant vous êtes une large
majorité à répondre non plus de 60% au
dernier pointage
béatrice est ce que vous partager l'avis
de la majorité des internautes du filion
bah oui oui c'est une évidence quand on
est à 215 milles morts dans son pays et
c'est pas fini et qu'on ose dire
n'ayez pas peur je veux dire combien
d'américains n'ont pas eu droit au
traitement de donald trump bien
évidemment donc c'est faire le fanfaron
voilà il est je parlerai pas d'audace
cessé un côté irresponsable et fanfaron
j'enlève mon masque mais il fait tout ça
pour quoi
parce qu'il est j'allais dire sur une
scène face à un public qui est son
public des lecteurs qui l'attendaient à
la sortie de l'hôpital face est sorti
dans cette voiture sans masque ou sur
tous et s'est fait dire gardes du corps
tout ça pour aller les voir parce que ça
lui fait du bien parce que il répond à
ça ça semble quand même absolument
dérisoire mais je pense que le côté on
va dire sérieux calme peut-être de ce
clip i
et puis donne comme il l'appelle c'est
peut-être lui qui engrange hayden
l'endormir baydan dans army wali les
fanfarons alexis on a publié ce matin un
figuier me santi formidable passionnant
de laure mandeville qui était notre
ancienne correspondante aux états unis
et qui aujourd'hui à paris mais qui
continue de suivre de près la situation
et qui est un volume est dans le chat
commet à ses yeux ce qui t'a rentrée
c'est du pur trump se dire c'est l'homme
qui il fait jamais il est toujours dans
l'excès dans dans l'eau dans la prise de
risque est là il est quoi ils se
trouvent
challenge et est dépassé par baï donnant
tous les sondages contesté sur la
gestion qu'il a eue de la sphère du coc
vide avec tout ce que l'on vient dire
très justement est donc qu'est ce qui
fait au lieu de se cacher au lieu il
profite de sa maladie pour en rajouter
et dire cette maladie qui n'existait pas
il ya huit jours
non sans mal existe mais il a vaincu et
elle est très forte elle a vaincu parce
que il est très fort et parce que
l'amérique est très forte
il redevient le porte-parole de de
l'amérique qui triomphe des méchants des
mauvais des faces de côté cow boys à la
mise en scène que vous avez pointé font
justement de cette série télévisée est
absolument incroyable
l'hélicoptère la musique parce que la
maison blanche a mis ça en diffuser ça
sur les réseaux sociaux avec en plus de
la hausse les valeurs comme si c'était
face à un film hollywoodien et c'est le
le taf kyle le le cow boys et john wayne
qui a vaincu les qui leur revient du
village indien il les a il les a battus
et maintenant c'est le plus fort alors
bon on peut juste à garein capture à
l'opus est grotesque et c'est la
question c'est pas nous ce que l'on
pense que ce que ceux des américains
vont penser à son électorat approuve
parfaitement on est je suis plus fort le
problème c'est est-ce que son électorat
suffire à le faire réélire
est ce que il a été élu en 2016 avec une
partie des électeurs qui venaient du
camp démocrate et qui ne sont pas
forcément il à 40% effectivement de la
population qui le soutient encore et qui
n'en démord pas mais on sait très bien
comment ce pas ces élections aux états
unis ça suffit pas il faut avoir ces
fameuses état le michigan la floride est
à la révolte et ses fameuses états
pivots ses étals incertain
un qui bascule et là tous les sondages
montrent que pour ya 12 à peu près état
pivot pour sept d'entre eux by john est
très nettement en tête
c'est à dire qu'il ramassera etc des
états peuplés
parce que il ya des petits et des gros
donc il met à la limite il fait le pari
là hein il joue la joojoo tapis il joue
la biomasse et voilà et et c'est pour ça
que je peux gagner sinon je reviens pas
cette saison je gagne pas de toute façon
il a perdu donc il a intérêt à jouer
double il y va à fond et ces temps de
voir comment cet homme qui enfin qu'il
fait ce que c'est le clivage incarner et
kiki qui ascal cette affaire de covin
comme clivages politiques fondamentales
de la vie politique américaine c'est
étonnant nous alors nous on a quand même
la sphère du professeur raoul t on sent
combien il ya des pro et des anti route
enfin la vie politique française ne
tourne pas autour de ça mais c'est comme
si on mettait ce clivage là au centre de
la vie politique américaine
il va transformer cette bataille
électorale en trop antico vite comme on
est comme si on devait être pro ou anti
de maladie et est donc sa position à lui
été d'abord d'en nier l'existence et
maintenant c'est d'en nier la
dangerosité puisqu'il l'a combattu et
vaincu ce étonnant comme le match et
qu'il n'a pas eu aussi fort que boris
brice johnson était dans une négation de
la gravité bon une fois qu'il a été
touché
et puis il ya eu bien peur hein parce
que ça a duré quand même plus que deux
jours on mais là on va bien voir parce
qu'il est sorti ce que vous avez montré
des médecins les médecins sont beaucoup
plus mesurés sont nous aurait dit il est
totalement guéri peut y aller
ils ont été beaucoup plus prenant du
temps il faut qu'ils continuent à se
soigner à la maison blanche et c'est
donc en jeu mais l'année des revues
souhaite pas mais en fort est normal
quand même non
évidemment pas tous deux souhaité que sa
maladie continue comme ça mais ceux qui
voient là ce qui me frappe c'est comment
il va installer cette affaire-là se
clive ce clivage là au centre de la
bataille électorale américaine est
opaque aujourd'hui parce que finalement
cette façon qu'il a caricaturale de se
mettre en scène
elle parle certainement oui monsieur et
elle est caricatural mais dans son genre
elle n'est pas moins quatre caricatural
qu'une autre culture américaine qu'il
fait face de ce point de vue les fêtes
du mandat trump c'est d'avoir deux
caricatures qui s'affrontent et trump
est d'autant le produit de cet
affrontement que le que celui qui
précipite cet affrontement
car en face de cette culture de l'homme
fort de ces la culture de des minorités
la culture snoflex et les flocons de
neige
on est dans la plainte dans j'ai été
offensés dans tout ça perd des dockers
il ya toute une amérique qui ne qui ne
se reconnaît pas dans cette culture de
de l'offensé de la minorité et qui au
contraire dit ah oui ça c'est ça c'est à
la mairie que c'est ça mais est-ce que
ils seront à gagner en jouant bien sûr
je sais absolument rien à personne mais
ça peut par exemple
voilà ça me paraît en tout cas tôt de
dire que on doit avoir une amérique
moins inégalitaire etc etc
donc c'est ça qui va être intéressant
est la question à laquelle on ne peut
pas toujours répondre c'est quelle va
être la mobilisation se délecteront qui
sera mobilisée ça on le sait mais quelle
sera la mobilisation de l'électorat
peinture bailon en particulier un
électorat jeune un kill donc mais en
creux c'est cet espacement de quelle
sera la position pour bayonne il y aura
pas de mouvement au delà vos questions
c'est qu'elle sera là où il y aura-t-il
une mobilisation anti tram suffisante
pour faire gagner bailon plaît parce que
bayonne il n'y a pas de queue de
charisme by day n'est pas d'adhésion à
la vida il ya simplement la question
c'est est-ce que cette amérique qui
exècre ce que représente trump va être
suffisamment nombreuses pour ça la poser
sur bayonne et d'en faire de bayonne
l'instrument d'un d'un stock propre et
tout dépend entre autres choses du débat
qui vaille à voir avec sa candidate vice
présidente qui avait un risque n'ont pas
lu et qui affronte le vice-président
notre oeuvre mais ça c'est peut-être
quelque chose parce que peut dire bailon
ou fond il finira peut-être pas son
mandat il est elle à ce moment là qui
prendra la suite vous 06 que trompeuse
n'ira pas jusqu'au bout de la grippe a
c'est vrai que les vice-présidents leur
arrêt un premier rôle
inattendu vous répondez à la question de
bert jammaer justement que pouvons nous
attendre du débat pence harris
je pense que demande si kamala harris
est forte en rhétorique
oui bon c'est ce qu'on verra donc ses
400 réparait pour ses sets mais on aura
des meilleurs les meilleurs moments à
retrouver dans l'est après après le
débat sur le sur le site du figaro nadia
nous dit ce dont il faut avoir peur
c'est de la bêtise abyss abyssal de
donald trump pas forcément ben ouais
j'irai pas ben non il est dans sa
logique il est dans sa logique et il
répond aussi à des attentes à sa
politique vis-à-vis de la chine
moi je la qualifierais pas de bêtes elle
est alors là pour le coup je la dirai
audacieuse cette façon c'est à dire
qu'ils osent affronter prendre à bras le
corps une situation qu'on a laissé filer
et s'installer donc je il est in
imprévisible il est parfois inattendues
il est éminemment contestable mais je
n'ai pas non plus une grande lumière non
mais il est plus dans un stade ou sur
vos dires un peu familièrement dingo que
bête il
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas la
même chose et moi je dirais que c'est la
réponse caricaturale d'une amérique à la
caricature faite d'elle par l'autre
amérique parce que trop python pas du
signalement bien je sais pas c'est pas
un gars qui a gagné comme ça par hasard
dont se dit tiens c'est bizarre il est
quand même un peu excessif non c'est
l'amérique qui en avait tellement marre
des démocrates et deux au fond du mépris
social démocrate il faut se rappeler
d'hillary clinton parlant de déplorable
c'est une espèce de système de gilet
jaune qu'il par dix cas aux états unis
où les élites démocrates les élites de
wyeth de la côte est se sont mises à
considérer le peuple américain comme des
moins que rien ne s'intéressant plus
grand que les journalistes et et donc du
coup cetin est vrai que c'est di méo et
se sont ils ont porté au pouvoir se
trame pour renverser ce système là et il
leur versait l ock que tout est
chamboulé de tout et par dessus tête et
peut-être maintenant ils vont dire il a
fini le job
la question qui est importante c'est que
s'ils contestent les résultats c'est à
dire il est près d'être à mettre pour
être au pouvoir en question les
institutions et la démocratie américaine
alors si il en arrive là là on sera
vraiment sur une situation qui sera
extrêmement grave parce que la première
puissance mondiale ce qu'elle est encore
qui mettra en cause la démocratie
alors autant vous dire que chez jean
ping et poutine vont se frotter les
mains d'avoir affaire est grave
à propos de sujets et poutine christophe
qui ne dit finalement cette épreuve
renforce trump ou trump a prouvé que ce
virus peut se guérir sans vaccin saas et
de l'audace et à prouver
heureusement il ya eu tout un chacun 4
18 au 19 % des gens qui font le vide qui
n'ont même pas de beaucoup de gens qui
l'ont prouvé avant lui à commencer par
mourad nous nous dit l inverse tout le
monde ne peut pas prendre un cocktail de
médicaments de luxe comme lui certains
disent même que c'est une mise en scène
électorale et
babineau nous dit je rejoins béatrice
giblin c'est une mise en scène grotesque
d'un homme qui tente de renverser la
vapeur au niveau des sondages vous poser
une question plus profonde
papa ça c'est que le monde entier a
confiné à la suite de lâcher et est ce
que si la maladie diminue que trump
gagne est-ce qu'il va pas servir pour
une partie du monde 2 à 2 contre le mans
2 2 contre modèle en disant il faut
vivre avec le virus ne va pas se laisser
dicter nos attitudes chez tout à fait
possible regard des vols soit 0 il a dit
j'ai eu le virus j'en suis sorti on
continue comme ça vous avez vous avez
aujourd'hui ça poutine il aurait le
virus je pense qu'ils auraient de danse
après regarde le ciel il faut pas non
plus tomber dans la caricature absolue
il y à fort taux de mortalité aux états
unis mais ce taux est supérieur à celui
d'afrique inférieur sud de l'espagne
donc c'est pas non plus c'est pas du
simple au double pas du tout c'est un
peu plus en morts par million dire que
ça touche quand même deux là sont très
inégales en fait il faut comparer quant
aux cons quand on dit il ya deux t5 et
le sens de 215,5 m
bah oui c'est des états unis il faut
comparer à l'europe pour palper la
france il ya maintenant vingt trente
mille oui bien sûr mais où 35 min mais
sur 65 minutes mais oui c'est il faut
faire rapporter à la pollution et à la
population
ce ne sont pas des bons résultats mais
ce sont des résultats qui s'insère entre
les nôtres ceux de ceux des espagnols
font pas c'est pas non plus le
non on est l'extermination de la
population et 15 h exagère avec n'est
pas l'hécatombe
la question qu'on me pose et sur le site
du figaro qu'on continue de vous poser
bon vous pouvez continuer à répondre
donald trump
at il raison de dire qu'il ne faut pas
avoir peur du coc vide
dix neuf est pour l'instant une lâche
majorité de non à 7 à cette question lui
qui nous dit
trump devrait éviter de fanfaronner trop
tôt les symptômes les plus préoccupants
apparaissent après la première semaine
de maladie les benjamins nous demande si
peines fait parler de lui depuis 2016
c'est un vice présidents présents mois
plutôt discret jusqu'à présent plutôt
discuter on va se poser une autre
question
elle concerne la prochaine loi sur le
séparatisme et enfin sur le séparatisme
si ça s'appelle comme ça puisque le
titre exact de la loi n'est pas encore
actée moins de cinq jours après le grand
discours des manades macro mureaux le
terme même de séparatisme donc pourrait
disparaître du projet de loi annoncé
vendredi en tout cas ce qu'a confié le
ministre d'intérieur ce matin sur radio
classique
ce ne sera sans doute pas son nom
puisque le président de la république a
évoqué dans son discours
quelque chose qui ressemblerait à un
projet de loi renforçant la laïcité et
les principes républicains
mais l'idéal est bien de lutter contre
le séparatisme principal qu'est l'islam
radical
mais ce n'est pas le seul objet du texte
d'ailleurs ce texte s'adresse à tous les
cultes s'adresse contre tous les
mouvements sectaires impose la
neutralité politique et religieuse tout
simplement est-ce que alexis est ce que
c'est un recul ou qu'importe qu'on parle
de laïcité ou préparer déjà avant
d'interpréter pour chrome os ne sont que
c'est bizarre on nous installe un mot
qui est pas un mot habituel on parlait
jamais de séparatisme parlant de dérive
de de l'islam politique
ça fait un an que macro l'install
puisque c'est le discours de mulhouse
qui a qui doivent rhin en février deux
minimes
voilà on martèle selon leur martèle on
le
on le dit de prison à vie est un grand
discours tout entier bâti sur ce concept
de séparatisme miso l'intérieur nous
fait ce sera 10 mai le jour où on arrive
au moment où il faut pondre la loire
n'est finalement pas plus dire
séparatisme à dire laïcité donc déjà il
ya quand même quelque chose à mon avis
ça ne peut pas être anodin si on a pu
utiliser ventes en deux temps un mot et
qu'on change de mots alors les mots
après les querelles de mots elles ont
une importance qu'elle est long mais
n'empêche que le fait de changer d'os a
quand même une importance et donc on a
réduit la pour l'instant aux conjectures
pourquoi est-ce qu'on change de moto
dans tout à coup ce que moi je crois
mais je on peut après avoir discuté avec
matrix mais j'ai le sentiment on sait
qu'il ya eu une dispute sémantique
autour du mot séparatistes fallait-il
parler du séparatisme grille des
séparatismes emmanuel macron en parler
commencé à parler à mulhouse du
séparatisme islamistes puis chemin
faisant c'est devenu les séparatismes
dans lequel on a mis pêle-mêle on a
parlé un peu secret maciste blanc les
suberaies insiste blanc les crises les
chrétiens les riches alors il ya de ces
partis ce bruissement hélas assemble de
janvier non mais attendez vous moquez de
nous un moment faut dire la vérité on
n'est pas en train de parler des
suppressions blanc des chrétiens des
juifs des musées des riches ou des je
sais pas quoi ou des corps sur des
bretons on parle du problème de l'islam
politique et donc on va reparler d'eux
le séparatisme et apparemment ça marche
jean todt et ramène on peut parler de le
séparatisme que le séparatiste c'est
stigmatiser les musulmans c'est pas bien
il faut pas faire ça et donc je me senti
mon intuition c'est que pour sortir de
ce dilemme entre ceux qui disent les ses
partitions et macron lui-même qui a dit
le séparatisme mais qui se fait
engueuler par une partie de son corps ou
ont changé on va dire la laïcité mais la
laïcité dans une certaine mesure cirque
en revenir à les séparatistes puisque la
laïcité face à la laïcité il ya les
religions donc on va nous expliquer
aprem de laïcité
jusqu'à présent j'avais pas vu qu'elle a
d'énormes problèmes avec les catholiques
avec les protestants ou avec les juifs
donc c'est une façon de ne pas dire
encore une fois que qu'on veut
s'intéresser aux dérives de l'islam
politique va être ils sûrs et deux
points qui a été soulevé et on pose la
question d'ailleurs aux internautes
parce que vous partagez de l'analyse
d'alexis est ce que d'abord c'est pas
anodin et ensuite est ce que justement
c'est une façon de
de gérer ce dilemme mais d'abord je
trouve que c'est la première fois qu'on
a un pouvoir et un président dans le
public quand même eu le courage ou et
nommer ceux qui étaient à nommer bon des
changements sarkozy l'a pas nommé lord
l'a pas nommé
l'idée qu'il fallait affronter cet islam
radical
donc ça c'est déjà un point très
important maintenant c'est dans le titre
qu'il n'y aura pas le terme d' islam de
séparatisme j'ai bien compris ce qu'a
dit l'art mana c'est dans le titre
alors on peut voir les choses et c'est
pour en débattre avec alexis on peut se
dire que une loi sur la laïcité on en
fait pas si souvent c'est elle va durer
dans le temps
on peut espérer que l'islamisme radical
avec un peu d'optimisme ne durera pas
dans le temps en revanche la loi qui
rappelle un certain nombre de principes
importants
c'est utile et qu'on peut vouloir mettre
ça sous le couvert de la laïcité mais je
suis d'accord avec l église qui est
l'objet même c'est l'islamisme radical
ceci étant rappelé y compris aux autres
religions les principes de la laïcité
même si on a des évangéliques qui sont
quand même un peu qu'ils peuvent être
créationnistes qui peuvent contester ce
qui s'apprend dans les écoles on a un
courant comme ça aujourd'hui enfin on a
le droit de penser ce qu'on veut
mais pas d'accord là la question c'est
l'islam poli mais vous que les dérives
pole mais on peut avoir les enseignants
évangélistes créationnistes qui diront
aux enfants non l'accord est venue la
loi va aborder ce a besoin de moi j'ai
entendu l'album on dit il faut pas
d'horaires différents fin je sais pas si
même la loi va le dire non 10 comme un
maire il ferait des je suis même pas sûr
qu'elle ose le dire ont elles dit je
sais pas que un maire qui verra quand on
aura le texte mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu curieux mais ce qu'on a dit c'est
que un maire qui compte un préfet
constatant créneau redonnant un emprunt
par le maire à nos principes
républicains pourraient se substituer au
maire et parmi ces emprunts aux
principes du cas il y aurait par exemple
les horaires différencier les rangs
serrés derrière la piété ou les mulets
menus halal et c'est déjà là encore on
ne parle pas on parlera des autres
religions on parle et les horaires
déférence et dans les piscines on parle
des ddt musulmans donc c'est encore dire
la laïcité vous l'avez dit vous-même
c'est quand même une façon de ne pas
vraiment dire les choses
après si le contenu hier si le contenu
est celle là c'est l'essentiel
nous on était les premiers à dire que le
discours d' emmanuel macron était un
discours aux courageux et intéressant et
riche de promesses
encore faut-il et mais la première chose
qu'on se dise et il faut encore faut-il
que d'ailleurs il ya les actes soient au
rendez vous je trouve que changer les
noms avant même d'avoir fait la loi
ça m'inquiète c'est peut-être aussi à un
ballon envoyé par darmanin ne s'est pas
arrêtée on sait pas a dit bon dans la
tête mais je reviens vous n'avez pas que
les piscines avec les normes vous avez
un enseignement vous pourrait un jour
avoir des enseignants de conviction
évangélistes qui pourront tenir des
discours qui n'auront rien d'ajouter la
cohabitation
on pourra même pas la question je vous
pose c'est que par exemple même si vous
avez aimé tomber ces enseignants dans
ces écoles étaient là ça provoque pas un
territoires perdus de la république
comme peu le printemps rue mais bien sûr
nous je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mais dans les territoires perdus de
la république on tombe sur une question
qui est beaucoup plus large qui est
celle effectivement de ce qu'on a appelé
les ghettos de ce qu'on appelle les
ghettos qui se sont renforcées donc on
peut
on peut expliquer il y avait un
excellent papier du recteur de la grande
mosquée de paris a été absolument
remarquable il ya quelques jours enfin
avant le discours dalaï lama il ferait
ainsi commis dans les bureaux on a fait
un deuxième temps à fait tord il a bien
fait deux tête à fait remarquable est ce
qu'il voulait venir chez et il dit bon
l'état a aussi laissé faire ce qui est
vrai on a aussi le livre de l'inspecteur
général aubin comment on va laisser
pénétrer d'islamisme dans l'école
c'est pour ça que je prenais l'exemple
de l'école parce que dans l'écologie il
ya des risques qui sont importants donc
il était temps ce qui veut dire que
c'est extrêmement important le discours
et du président de la république si
derrière alors on met en place une
politique encore on est encore dans les
temps les autres sinon ça sera dia dans
le discours du président il est comment
dire les fondements tout théorique tout
faire des choses encore faut-il les
faire
ouais alors il ya 200 petits deux
obstacles les décades le premier cas
d'obstacle juridique
je dis attention aux conseils consulaire
au conseil d'état au tribunal
administratif
toutes les mesures annoncées hier par lé
sont susceptibles d'être invalidée
contestée par les tribunaux illustratif
le passeur pour l'arc en ciel qui vont
choisir des juristes pour rédiger sanaa
oui mais attendez dire par exemple que
vous interdisez l'instruction domicile
pas gagné pas à gagner ces libertés
fondamentales de pour les parents de
données dont il ya onze enfants pas
gagné du tout dire qu'un préfet peut se
substituer un élu local
parce qu'il considère que ce qui a fait
les locales n'est pas
juridiquement fondée c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe dans la loi c'est que
c'est le tribunal administratif qui doit
le dire ben si le tribunal admistratif
dit que les locales a le droit de faire
des horaires différencier ou a le droit
de faire un menu à la loi le droit de
ceux ci ou a le droit de cela le préfet
y peut penser ce qu'il veut c'est pas
lui qui décide
donc je dis attention il ya quand même
un verrou juridique lac qui est donc il
va falloir se bagarrer et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que la loi ne peut pas se
contenter de demi mot parce que pourquoi
le conseil les tribunaux administratifs
peuvent chaque fois que on l'a vu cent
fois et notamment du temps de sarkozy
que le préfet c'est d'expulser un imam
de fermer une mosquée
trois fois sur quatre quatre fois sur
cinq c'est le fruit d'un registre hâtif
qui dit non mais c'est pour ça que la
loi est bien il traque de chèvres à
condition qu'elles soient explicites et
ce qui me fait peur dans cette loi c'est
tout le flou qui la nabe l'implicite le
lala ici la laïcité c'est pas ça qu'il
faut dire il faut entrer précisément
dans ce qui est possible et ce qui n'est
pas possible sinon les tribunaux
administratifs e et hop se glisseront
dans les adversités et rien ne se
passera rien de génial moi je n'ai
aucune raison de penser qu'ils soient
pas aussi malin que vous et moi et qui
ne pige pas penser qu'il puisse
réveiller ils sont pas mal à ce qu'ils
ont peur le savent un fait qui n'osent
pas parler de 10 lagesse il parle de
laïcité me laisse à penser qu'il ya une
réticence politiques idéologiques qui
fait qu'on a du mal à dire les choses
mais j'espère me tromper
si la loi est rédigée précisément ça
peut être un outil notamment pour les
préfets pour faire le boulot en si la
loi est rédigée de façon fout rien ne
change en tout cas il a pris son temps
plein ce discours on lui avait reproché
il annonce il annoncé le 10 paille de
l'annoncé il annonce il le dit pas il a
pris son temps pour le dire est un
endroit qui était important les mureaux
donc s'il a pris ce temps là on peut
penser qu'elle ne sera pas rédigé sur un
coin de table et qu'ils prendront les
juristes de qualité pour pouvoir écrire
avec l'avis du conseil constitutionnel
avant de se lancer il ya un autre point
qui me paraît il mérite qu'on s'y arrête
un instant c'est mais ce n'est pas
encore clair donc là encore on le verra
dans le texte l'idée qu'il faut peu ou
prou revoir la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité parce que j'ai on n'a pas très
bien compris à brommat compris le bain
on est d'accord il a attaqué j'ai
compris que
il fallait plutôt permettre aux tout ce
qui était les associations de sur le
modèle de l'association de loi de 1901
et que en particulier pour le culte
musulman et qu'il fallait qu'il rentre
dans we lire le cadre normal pour les
cultes de la loi de 1905 avec les
avantages et les inconvénients qu'elle
peut avoir bon et qu'il n'était pas
qu'on n'allait pas les laisser un moment
où le président dit quitte à revoir à la
loi de 1905 qui doit elle-même il ya
quelque chose comme ça et notamment
quand il aborde la question de la
formation des imams
il ya un truc qui me si la tentation
était mais je ne dis pas que c'est ça
mais il faut commander votre vigilant
là-dessus était de dire en gros c'est
l'état qui va former les imams sur fonds
publics pour leur donner maintenant
tampon et policiers d'abord à sa serait
absolument inefficace ont maintenant mes
deux ce serait grave sur le plan des
patrick moi je trouve que c'est
clairement pas ça je susi ce que ça a
été dit à deux reprises et ce n'est pas
à l'état d'organiser et de s'occuper de
la formation des ddt imams ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'on est censé justement
les faire rentrer à ce moment là
emmanuel macron même a invoqué la
séparation oui oui mais dit qu'il faut
quand même revoir le dispositif légal
pour que le cfcm puisse donner un coût
de 2,2 et donc ça veut dire qu'ils
feraient ça en s'adossant à dispositif
législatif si j'ai bien conduit
moi je sais pas j'ai plutôt compris dans
le sens de vos il ya un flou je pense
qu'il ya un flou alors sa prestation n'a
pas
bon débarras c'est intéressant oui
monsieur ne s'était pas du tout sera
déposée qu'en décembre
donc on attend dans le temps d'en
reparler mais je pense que c'est quand
même un point sur lequel il faut voilà
auquel il faut faire attention enfin si
ça n'est pas très bien mais c'est un
texte important vraiment important c'est
à dire courageux parce que il faut aller
contre tout un discours d'islamophobie
et autre chose l'appui du grand recteur
de la mosquée de paris est évidemment un
atout et est certes mais il ne faut pas
attendre que le grande mosquée où le
scénar et m puisse avoir le moindre
contrôle sur les imams aujourd'hui c'est
pas il n'ya pas d'instance qui peut
donner un label deux ans pour devenir
imam c'est pas vrai il y en aura pas les
musulmans lors récusons ce qui permet
parfois aussi d'avoir des femmes imams
éclairé ouvert intelligent qu'il y en a
quelques-unes
espérons qu'il y aura de plus en plus je
ne montrerai pas dans ce débat juste
peut-être un point qui mérite aussi
concerté une seconde c'est cette affaire
sur la langue
sur le 2 l'idée est là encore je trouve
qu'il ya un souci d'équilibré mois ont
dit on va supprimer les locaux qui sont
ces fameuses enseignement et par des
associations
en fait financer par l'algérie le maroc
et la tunisie dans le primaire et la
turquie dans le primaire pour apprendre
la langue arabe qui sans faire des
courtes de cours de catéchisme le coran
on dit on va supprimer sa dé aussitôt en
rajoute
mais il faut absolument développer la
langue arabe dans une grande langue
bah oui mais ce qu'il faut la développer
ce code il faut développer le portugais
il faut développer les semaines en tant
qu' il n'y a pas le dit très bien faut
il faut fournir l'enseignement mais je
trouve qu'il ya cette volonté de dire
que entre nous soit dit pour toute cette
jeunesse quand on dit qu'elle est en
déshérence en rupture en tentation de
séparatisme est-ce que la base c'est pas
le français apprendre le français
apprendre à parler vous d'apprendre
enfin tout dépend à quel niveau vous
fait vous faites quand j'enseignais
l'arabe
si vous enseigner l'arabe en seconde
première et terminale comme une langue
parce que c'est pas et donc si facile
que ça non de ce que vous ne l'enseigné
pas en prime elle est rapidement et
correctement et s'est essayé à ce
qu'elle soit plus de demande et afin que
nous ayons plus de ged et dire
d'intellectuels qui sache parler l'arabe
qui ne comprennent cette lande et qu'ils
puissent faire jaillir des recherches de
qualité
en a quelques-uns des jeunes formés
c'est vrai comme ils seront mais c'est
vrai que si on en avait beaucoup plus ce
serait je serai pas plus mal pour
comprendre le monde arabe alors cet
internaute le dis je ne vois pas en quoi
je suis renseigné la rave à l'école
lutterait contre le séparatisme en
revanche imposés cole sera beaucoup plus
tard c'est pas accepter en primaire en
europe
mais ce sera en tant qu à emmanuel magat
monde en sont les secours dit que les
l'innovation par rapport à soi sans
saignement la sait que ça va être des
professeurs et je devrais être
estampillé par l'éducation nationale
on n'a pas été assez peu d'élèves qui
aujourd'hui le demande parce que c'est
vrai et on les aura pas donc bon et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les familles
qui demandent à ces pour ce sont faux
parce que ces choses ce n'est pas pour
apprendre une langue c'est pour des
motifs religieux c'est pour le camp et
dans les bals classe mais dans les
petites cassel sont l'enseigne pour
ainsi dire pardon mais on va prendre il
y en a 50 au centre-ville enfants qui
vivent dans les cours de celle qu'on
s'est beaucoup achètent dans chaque
et bien pour des motifs religieux
babineau qu'ils étaient d'accord avec
que béatrice dans le premier débat est
plutôt d'accord avec vous alexis jeu sur
les allusions babineau un partout je
suis d'accord avec alexis on sent une
gêne d'emmanuel macron autour de ces
sujets ils s'engagent à reculons les
premières victimes nos dia dld dans le
monde des islamistes radicaux sont les
musulmans ne l'oublions pas et je petit
quine ou redis j'ai l'impression que
c'est la république qui plie face à
l'islamisme et non l inverse
et puis que doit être forte et rome nous
dit la laïcité à la base a été une
bataille contre l'église
aujourd'hui on veut que cela soit contre
l'islam
non je crois pas que ce soit une
bataille contre l'islam
on a eu effectivement le petit père
combes comme clemenceau tout ça a été
bien connu avec des luttes qui était
juste une virée en vrai la moitié du
tiers du card bas il ya des faits à
l'époque la wii
l' affaire des fiches fameux l'expulsion
des configs à 100 par dizaines de
minimum les hits on à l'histoire de la
révolution française dont il a fait un
bon choix la rappellera le livre de jean
sevilla qui s'appelle quand les
catholiques étaient hors la loi et
sédition bah oui bon donc là je pense
non justement je pense que on n'est pas
dans quelque chose qui soit contre
l'islam il est extrêmement important et
c'est moi j'approuve totalement le
président là dessus et ceux qui ne
tiennent le même discours de mettre
vraiment le holà à l'iss à l'islamisme
politique c'était déjà ce que voulait
faire manuel valls très clairement et
mais à l'époque il n'a pas eu le même
soutien on va dire génial les esprits de
tes parents
et pourtant on a voulu faire avant lui
sarkozy
et oui sarkozy avait voulu organiser les
sam de france avait été un échec valls
avait rejeté le français est ce que
l'état dont a convenu est-ce que tu es
tu auras doit pas organe non slave de
france je suis d'accord là dessus on est
à 100% d'accord mais faut pas fermer
deux mois faut pas mêler mais la loi est
la loi un jour j'aimerais bien avoir
justement votre explication sur ça mais
ce sera l'objet d'un autre d'un autre
débat ont posé la question sur twitter
est ce une bonne idée de remplacer le
mot séparatisme par laïcité dans le
futur projet de loi contre le
séparatisme et vous répondez une large
majorité non à 73%
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
merci alexis merci béatrice pour ce
débat riche et on se retrouve très vite
sur le plateau cryolife demain
rendez-vous même heure même endroit avec
guillaume enquête
[Musique]